all right i got a brand new hour of
stand-up comedy tickets on sale right
now san francisco september 8 to the
10th all the tickets almost gone
tarrytown sold out we got madison
wisconsin milwaukee wisconsin chicago
illinois minneapolis minnesota london is
sold out dublin is sold out belfast
still some tickets we may add shows of
the uk in october christy comedy.com for
all the tiki wikis thanks for the
support
black blocker all right
all my tickets are on sale right now i'm
supposed to be filming my special in the
spring of 23 so if you want to see the
special before it's filmed come on out
canada for the first time in october uh
hamilton and toronto toronto second show
added then we're going to richmond
virginia and hershey pa hershey pa
second show added knoxville uh atlanta
and uh birmingham atlanta second show
edit that's with adam ray
louisville and evansville in november
and then we got florida and california
in december california is you guys been
asking me to come in sacramento san jose
and santa rosa so come on out
jacksonville all on sale right now at
[Music]
don't run savolcanocomedy.com from your
feelings babe don't be afraid don't be
ashamed don't hesitate to say hey all
right the h the e the y the b the a the
b the e
it's
it's hey babe
hey babe what's up baby this couch is
towering i hate the couch i uh you see
i'm going on record
i am thankful that the couch was here
but i don't after being in the count
with the couch one with the couch i'd
like to get rid of the couch
i agree and it's no disrespect to the
owner of the couch i just i just hate
this i hate this
this is the couch that everyone talks
about do you ever watch a architectural
digest open door
it's a very popular couch it's the cloud
couch from restoration hardware it's no
it's not it's it's not small tell digest
open the door
park it tell digest open the door i
don't know it well you just said
architect architect architectural digest
open the door you said it's the name of
the open door oh open architel dodge i
guess it doesn't work architecturally i
thought the architecture will digest
open the door but what are you singing
you know my love open the door
[Music]
that's what you pulled out of your ass
wait you were singing let my love by
pete townsend yeah let my love open the
door to your heart to your heart
because it's the end of the movie and
it's at the end of look who's talking is
it really yes oh it's also so i was
trying to do it it's also the end of
jersey girl i think because you said
architectural dye just opened the door
so i was trying to do architecture oh
open door okay see you textual digest
open the door
but it's let my love open the door okay
no but but but i don't know why you know
that so i can't i would have never made
if you would have bet me a billion
dollars i would lost a billion dollars
if you would lost a billion dollar if
elon musk loses a billion dollars he
still has about another 20 billion
dollars way more than that no you think
is any worth hundreds of billions how
much money is too much money sell
how much money is too much money
i think in today's day and age if you
want to live a moderate lifestyle not
worry about anything not moderate if you
want to have
200
[Music]
that's the answer
if i was elon musk tell the audience
he's worth
a quarter of a trillion dollars
257 billion us dollars why can't he just
give one member of his family the point
three
he just
just
by the way isn't the 0.3 in that
scenario 300 million so why don't you
just give somebody the 0.3 the 0.3 can
save a nation
literally 0.3 would get ukraine out of
this map that's why people
that's why people hate on them yeah
because he has too much money but what
are you gonna do if he lost he could
take a billion dollars and wipe his ass
with it and throw it at you and then put
gasoline on it light over the match it
all goes up in flames and he can
moonwalk out of there and he doesn't it
doesn't even affect him if you put i
think that it was steve jobs i heard
this with neil degrasse tyson if you
put
all
steve jobs money now elon musk has i put
i think twice as much money okay if you
put all his money in dollar bills u.s
singles
from earth to the moon and back like 700
times or something
that doesn't make sense it doesn't it
would wrap around the earth like like
ten thousand times you told me this once
and i was blown away
yeah so so so wait what the hell are we
just looking at what a piece of [ __ ]
steve jobs is 250 million dollars no no
no no no by age 25. oh well that's okay
he's worth
and that's equivalent to 745 million
now when he was 25. he's got to be worth
more than that
do you think elon musk looks at it do
you think if steve jobs still alive
because elon because steve jobs is so
poor elon musk would put his mask on
when he's around stephen thank you i
don't want to get you i think i think it
was that's how crazy
yeah so elon musk has more money than
most gross domestic products of nations
he has more money than most nations gdps
i'd imagine
many that's your answer right many
countries don't have 257.3
i think most yeah they don't right i
think the united states has to we got
trillions on trillions we got stacks we
got we got bands
well go up uh pimpy you just had it i
dropped a gross domestic product on me
what do you i mean you hit me with a gdp
i wanna listen
i wanna i wanna say that the reason why
um um
i'm a uh uh
hitting with a gross domestic uh product
the gdp why i'm feeling in a good mood
is because yesterday for the first time
ever in my life i took a bite of
mushrooms i did mushrooms actually on
this couch
actually a horrible couch just to come
back full circle actually
get up one second i think that a piece
of the mushroom fell out of my mouth and
might be
you like lucky charms right now that's a
piece of the mushroom that i ate
yesterday i swear to god
you dropped it oh now my kid's going to
find it you got to be careful you don't
want to drop this on the floor yeah did
you ever see that happen i think what's
his name sienna what's her name sienna
she's dragged to jude law uh sienna
college uh no santa miller that's her
name right i could swear that one time
the kid ate ecstasy off the floor in the
house that's not good can you google
that
i think it was a thing i think that like
they freaked out because like oh freak
out
now you should yeah judd
judge
scandal
now i
it doesn't come right up it was a news
story i remember it
are you ready to play a little fairy
kill real quick
all right here we go you ready yeah
marry kill
jude law hey jude law and order
um okay
i
hate you just played out
so you can't but it is but it is iconic
okay
well
i gotta have sex with jude law
jude law snip that use that as a clip
that's it
with no context and then i gotta i think
i got
a clue
[Laughter]
enough with it enough you know yeah and
then and then i never even seen an
episode and then you'll marry hey jude
and i'll marry hey jude because that's
fun um here we go london england which
i'll be at uh in october the show
october 6th at the bloomsbury theater is
sold out so we will be adding shows
hopefully friday saturday so check the
website christycomic.com for tickies
look at that
the two-year-old daughter of film stars
drew law and sadie frost sadie oh so it
wasn't stan i'm sorry was rushed to a
london hospital after she swallowed part
of an ecstasy tablet at a children's
party
they were calling a hospital staff after
toddler spent the night under
observation
uh she the kids and the kids in the
lobby the kids in the uh like the the
the uh
intensive care unit with glow sticks
they're bringing her bottle with the
sparkles on if they're like it just
helps with the
pack she's like you already got the
pasta yeah yeah
uh iris law had to endure a stomach pump
and brain scan oh that's the scariest
thing
i've ever heard by the way like
where's there just ecstasy why is it
ecstasy on the florida children's i was
going to say a scott yeah the police
have to get involved a scot scotland
yard spokesperson said we were called at
4 11 p.m which is 15 31 gmt i don't
have any idea
how to do time in the uk 4 11 p.m it's
15 31 gmt what are we talking you're
making it more difficult for yourselves
yeah you go from one to twelve that's
it's so hard what is gm 15 30. meet me
there at 1 531 gmt yeah how about meet
me there at four four would be great
well how about i i posted the flyers and
you know in in the uk you know june 10th
is 6 10. uh that's annoying june 10th is
10 6 6. so i'm saying i'm in london
october 6 10 6 22 and they're like it
happened already june 10th you were
already there can you just know that
americans are we are the way we are and
just understand that it's october yeah i
got flooded with messages like june 10th
already happens yeah and you know they
know they're looking at they know what
happened yeah you know i know but they
want to tell you that it passed yeah
they want to tell you that's impossible
you were there in june that means yeah
and instead of just being like or
they'll say uh don't you mean october
6th yes i'm gonna yeah that's what i
mean you know what i'm gonna tell you i
my shows are at 8pm london [ __ ] time
that's what time they are like
okay figure it out figure it out at
whatever time dmt that is then that yeah
i was like
2671 gmf yeah i'm at my dmt this looks
like a fun party venue for you the child
had been attending a children's birthday
on saturday where she was believed to
have picked up a tablet that had been
left on the floor of the premises in old
compton on old compton street the
premises had been used as a bar and
nightclub on friday
excuse me
i thought she found it in their home
that's
that's insane i wonder what the
differences are between compton
california and old compton england
they both drink old english probably
they probably yeah nice thank you thank
you um yeah i'll tell you something
right now imagine like the mo
your kid takes ecstasy by accident
you're looking and you're like this is
you you're losing your [ __ ] you might
die of a coronary yourself of course the
kid's like relax dad is the best day of
my life
let's go to the hospital the hospital's
cool how's it going yeah let's go i'm
not people go to the hospital
at the hospital she starts pulling her
diapers i just want to be free
women did this happen in soho house
a spokesman for london saw house club
wow this happened at the soul house
that's where you're staying that's where
i'm staying oh my gosh oh wait should we
have said that well there's like ten of
them okay okay don't find me it's like
where in the world is
wow
it was a private matter and because it
was regarding members i'm not allowed to
say anymore yeah also because the police
are [ __ ] probably investigating yeah
i can't speak about a child being
drugged because we're behind the paywall
would you have delilah's birthday in a
soho house [ __ ] rave it out could i
have delilah's birthday at a soho house
why not no here's what i'll say fun
weird actually maybe because at least
the solo house in new york the children
can use the pool before noon it'd be
nice it'd be here's what i tell you i'm
not doing as just having two kids and
going through this i am not ever again
having a children's birthday party at my
house
done i would bring up your mind i'm
renting out your establishment yeah
whether it be the pool whether it be the
arcade i'm renting your place out for
two hours i'm giving you whatever you
tell me the cost is i'm paying it
willingly to you okay so i don't have to
do anything but bring my children there
and then bring them home do you mean
to you
the royal you or you mean me when when i
what
do you mean
i want to bring them to your house there
you are and i'll you tell them
you mean the house house you throw the
party all right you throw the party if
you if you think that i wouldn't throw
your daughter a birthday party at my
house just on the arm you're crazy
i i you can i'll i will throw her a
party i will throw them a party
you're known for remembering things like
like freakishly long i'm telling you
right now pimp
save this clip i'm telling you right now
[Music]
you are throwing my daughter sweet 16 at
your home i know
it's in it's in nine years i'll tell you
what i have to say to that
i need to have sex with jude law
[Music]
no uh uh 100
sweet 16
it's in may so it'll be nice weather
it's nine years it's in nine years for
sweets yeah i mean you you got it i mean
you got it it's confirmed yeah but just
the just the guest list um just make
sure there's no crazies we'll keep it
under 50.
family and people that will stay cool
yeah yeah because i love the first
person who shows at the house it's like
takashi
[Laughter]
i have a question for you guys best best
childhood birthday
oh wow best childhood birthday
um i remember a surprise party i had
once i thought that was pretty neat
you know it might have been my first
surprise party you never had a surprise
party right no actually you know what's
crazy i don't remember oh you did have a
surprise that was that i was gonna say i
don't i i remember
almost none of my birthdays certainly
not one from childhood besides the time
all my friends got their tongues pierced
and nobody could eat the chicken fingers
my mom bought from corrado's pizzeria
and ridgewood big mistake 16. that was
my that was my sweet 16.
um
everywhere you had a mass tongue
piercing yeah and i was there but the
guy tried to pull my tongue out and he
said it's too short he couldn't do it
your tongue tied
i am too
much i could do
we probably have the shortest tongues of
any podcast in the world yeah the short
tongues cast we got we're the short
we're the short tongue podcast
but i will say honestly shout out to
jessica may paluso isn't she the short
time of shopping shout out jessie may
yes um so so so we have um the birthday
party that i was thrown last year
surprise party for my 37th birthday i
would say because now it's a year has
passed is the only birthday i really
remember other than my 16th birthday and
i remember one other one when i was 31
years old because jasmine had put up 31
31 surprise gifts around the house and i
remember not being able to find about 19
of them
yeah
that's such a good idea little gifts and
like tie and i remember that's getting
about 12 or 13 in and being like i don't
do you want it because my delight i
believe i'm 12. yeah my my daughter was
with my mom like i was like do you want
to just stop you want to just have sex
like let's just can we just stop this
and let's we did 12 let the other 18
will be 18 sexes yeah uh but that one
but i do remember the party surprise
party that you were there yeah joe de
rosa almost a year ago my birthday last
year my 37th
i remember i remember it because i was
like i remember checking in we was at
this i think it was the rooftop of the
was it the stand not the standard it was
the uh um what is that hotel the conrad
maybe conrad maybe it was a roof it was
a downtown manhattan rooftop and i
remember you know knowing that it was my
birthday but not really honestly i i
truly was shocked and i get up there and
we're checking i wasn't there for the
surprise you weren't there for this yeah
i got there like a couple minutes late
and and i remember though
like
the there was a problem at the desk at
the front desk because
jasmine put her credit card down but for
some reason it wasn't going through and
i put my credit card i remember this
down and i remember like i remember
being like oh whatever not thinking
about anything because she said oh i
just pre-bought a table because it gets
so powerful right right and then out of
the corner of my eye i see joe derosa
sitting there drinking and drinking i'm
like how weird is this deroza's here too
i swear to god
stop not thinking at all it's for me
i swear to god i'm like what a weird
outside i can't wait to be like what up
dick you know like and then meanwhile i
walked in and everybody was i had no
[ __ ] idea
i'll never forget i had to help sneak tt
in she didn't have a vax card that was
like back that was back then yeah she
didn't have a vax cart that's right tt
was there too how do you sneak into
someone like tt how do you solve a
problem like maria do you know what
that's from
west side story no still never seen it
yeah
it's worth a look you know we're going
to watch west side story patreon
i was uh one time i was uh on a date or
something like that i was dating a girl
and we and uh that she liked west side
story and she's like let's watch it i
was like i'll watch it and i was like
why don't we make it fun and i had never
seen it before i said why don't we do a
shot every time someone says maria oh my
god yeah it was not we got we were
hammered yeah we couldn't do it i
couldn't do it but i i did as many shots
i could do you could how about this i
went to there's a new movie theater on
staten island called the alamo
drafthouse
have you been have you went through i i
haven't been there yet i've heard all
about i've seen the photos so me and
delilah went to see how how's the movie
viewing experience it's supposed to be
good at those places movie viewing
experience was awesome we saw annie but
the 1980s version yeah so we saw annie
because they play old-school movies
they had for the summer they had like a
kids camp where like for five bucks you
can go with your kid they played annie
they played goosebumps they play all
like kids movies so me and delilah went
we're sitting there
having a great time delilah you know you
can write down like the way it works is
a waitress comes over and you have a
little notepad and a pencil you look at
the menu and you write down what you
want so i said delilah you write you
write it down you write down what you
want and you know and she shows me you
know she's asking me dad how do you
spell milkshake you know because i'm
letting her do it i'm like daddy wants
whatever a burger so should b you so
then she's like daddy right you know
writes down milkshake so how do you
write down milkshake so i tell her oreo
milkshake you're spelling out whatever
all of a sudden you know give gives it
to the waitress waitress comes back she
goes okay
comes back
look she just assumed as a parent i
approved
delilah had put oreo milkshake dash five
the weight just comes back with five
oreo milkshakes
[Laughter]
they had two weight staff members come
out holding their friends
and delights because daddy did that
no it cost me like 95 dollars for
everything like annie for five bucks
you know and i was like holy [ __ ] but
and she literally i swear to god
five yeah she's so funny
she took a sip she took maybe three sips
of a milkshake and fell asleep in the
movie
and i was like i said to the waitress
after i was like did you like i can't
believe you brought it all five she goes
i assumed you approved
i said okay i
dude let me just tell you let me tell
you one thing quick and then we'll do
that
um you say things enough on a podcast
you're like oh maybe i'll get sick of
saying it
three words i'm not sick of america's
number one meal kid which is four words
that's right four words i'm not sick of
saying it america's number one meal kids
no it's five words what it is you're
still not sick of them i'm not sick of
it at all
and it's hello fresh it's hella fresh
hola fresca uh olaf
uh with hellofresh let's just tell them
what they get in case in case you've
been living under a rock yeah and you
haven't tuned in before this episode let
them know pimpin
with hello flesh
without the fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery stove and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it is america's number one meal kit
we've been using it since day one you
got 20-minute meals 30-minute meals you
could customize what you get
they're always updating their recipes
and ingredients
they are the best hello fresh i use it
my family uses it the 20-minute meal
preps it's even taught me how to cook
it's given me confidence it's got my
health in check the whole family loves
it they got vegan meals veggie meals
meat meals and it ain't just dinner no
they got breakfast they got wholesome
snacks they got desserts they got lunch
they got everything yeah hello fresh is
the move for you it's something that
i've been living by literally i i want
to just actually from a personal uh
standpoint thank you to hellofresh for
even existing that's right i appreciate
you guys we're huge fans
and the discount is incredible
phenomenal phenomenal almost like we
question week after week how this
company makes money because they give so
much stuff away free don't understand
the business model hellofresh.com
slash hey babe 16 use the code hey babe
16
16 free meals across seven boxes and
three free gifts so just for putting in
our promo code you get 16 free meals
like you literally get weeks worth of
food for free i could be like 16 meals
i'm sold and then you like entry free
gifts why not
why not seven boxes of it hellofresh.com
hey vape 16 use code hey babe 16. 16
free meals across seven boxes and three
free gifts
hello fresh americans number one meals
three words for you
what do you think we've been doing folks
probably i'm on my babble app it's a
language learning app that i have that i
use to learn languages in a new fun way
because it's not done by ai it's done by
language experts and they have over 14
languages and they have bite-sized
lessons and i do it on my commutes i do
it on the toilet
it's addictive
on the toilet addictively fun okay i
want to tell you i'm gonna tell i'm
gonna look at the camera right now and
say i have a problem i'm addicted to
babble wow i love babble i'm addicted i
can't get off i don't want to get off
the best time in my life so far
yes and and it there's not just language
learning lessons right they do podcast
games videos stories live classes they
got a 20-day money-back guarantee
start the language learning journey
right now with babel save up to 60 of
your subscription when you go to
babble.com
hey babe that's babble.com hey babe
we're up to 60
off your subscription babble
language for life
this is an adhd app because i think we
dropped off like five topics no we did
but there's something i have to tell you
that that you didn't know about that we
were discussing before the show that i i
i
if i would be willing to give point
three uh if elon musk gave me the point
three yeah i'd transfer it to an account
if it meant you could go back in time
and be at a moment that you missed
at jo de rose's birthday party
out at joe derosa's birthday party jojo
rose's uh birthday oh the pig roast the
pig i couldn't make that that so we were
there outside jojo roses recently
recently outside joe derosa's sandwich
your birthday's like 10 days apart yeah
his is august 6 or something mine's the
26th so outside joe derosa's sandwich
shop which by the way go to yelp right
now and give joey roses five stars go
give it five stars right now yes yes yes
we don't say that enough go give that
thing five stars best sandwiches in new
york city give it five stars so here
don't don't show me up so so so but
after i after i say it then show them so
you never seen this clip you don't know
what no idea okay let me let me set the
stage for you right now let me see right
now
i can already tell we do the pig roast
yeah we're having a great time it's
roasted on the sidewalk it's roasted on
the sidewalk
so
it's roasting on a new york city
sidewalk yeah people are so what about
all the people passing by they were like
watching
what about the germs from the street
that's what joey's handing out pieces of
the pig he's like try the pig i'm like
i'm not eating a pig off the new york
city street right okay a couple photos
yeah this is hit it's crazy oh someone
put a cigarette in his pig's mouth yeah
pimped it
[Laughter]
so
so
so
it is okay you ready for this we're all
standing outside the bar the ac broke in
joey rose's it broke it broke and what
about what about every homeless person
walking by did he give them did he give
him a pig
probably okay he lit
your q every question you have is valid
because we were all like
dumbfounded why this was happening okay
so so so we are standing there outside
the the whole bar pretty much is filing
outside we're having a good time it's
just it's just become an outdoor party
people crowd around now there's garbage
there's a big pile of garbage there's a
pig roast and there's a barricade okay
okay joey rose's
it is me
joe derosa ari shafir
big jay olkerson josh out of myers ian
fine dance homeless pimp venetia
standing against the wall looking this
way just standing against the wall
looking to say as if god himself
said you're gonna need to see what i'm
about to show you okay
we're standing there all of a sudden we
hear a scream
and we hear a voice say oh i just fell
into the garbage
one of the waitresses at that works for
joey roses was going to lean back and
smoke a cigarette on a barricade
yes yes
flipped over the barricade into a pile
of wet garbage and it just rained in
front of seven new york city
joe derosa goes oh my god are you okay
and our spirit goes of course she's not
okay she just fell into a pile of
garbage in front of seven new york city
comedians literally show the clip
show this we were we couldn't believe
what just happened
what oh you caught a quarter on tape
clutch yeah
[Laughter]
glasses you only the guy that married
his daughter
[Laughter]
literally
fell into a [ __ ] pile of garbage and
we were
we did a full she
and then got up and was like she came
over soaking wet and she was like i'm
pretty embarrassed right now and we were
like yeah yeah you should i said you
shouldn't be you shouldn't be but it is
crazy you just fell in hot garbage this
just just went from a pig roast to a
euro so what you roast exactly
i mean literally you fell into a pile of
hot garbage you know sorry less
hurtfully
yeah
dude it was we see it again yeah just go
to the po where she flips over and if
you see her and you recognize it from
the video just you know give her give
her a good tip and not always yelp uh
five stars for joy roses but go
go it's it's truly truly great it is fun
i love sitting in the back room too like
that kind of picture of his family 70s
85 that that's one of my favorite parts
of any bar the bar is really cool it's
it's it's like just a cool space it's
like the vibe is cool and the sandwiches
are f i'm
the only way it could be better if it
was on staten island that's right it's
the only way
you you're like mr staten island i i i'm
even finding more places out about
staten island it's getting crazy um
so
look at i mean could you imagine in
front of seven new in front of like guys
look at the lady
she was like oh [ __ ]
look at the dog even
the dog is like how did she not see that
yeah yeah the dog's like oh [ __ ] is that
hari shafir
she fell in front of big j
[Laughter]
um so that was one of that was a moment
that i remember almost instantly being
like i wish sal was there oh because it
was one of those things that we do i
mean we talked we've talked about it
everything we started group texts
we're constantly talking about in
finance to bring up one good point joe
invited everyone to his birthday but
didn't charge for sandwiches yeah ian
finance is smart guy yeah let's hear
that
on the radfield streets of new york city
they're charging us
for sandwiches oh yeah you mean the way
a business works
your birthday party
dude dave such a genuine clapback yeah
yeah because to me it's like i
understand the business but it's like
you said this was your birthday party
i'll pay but
that's something i didn't mention about
the sweet 16.
what uh the guests will have to pay for
what things pay for drinks and stuff
well yes
unless unless we can get um what we
should do but hopefully by then we
should be able to have the peanut butter
sponsored by saratoga shout out to
chelsea peanut butter have the seven
flavors on the way new flavors on the
way um we should be able to be also be
sponsored by um what we have
videographer we got that
um what else will we have
who else do we have connects with
i know somebody who does balloon animals
oh it's the sweet 16 though balloon
animals
well you know we'll get the caterpillars
we'll provide the catering easy hello
fresh america's number one meal kit not
joey roses
it depends what joey rose type of price
roses wants to bring
no joe yeah fine joey rhodes you don't
want joey roses to bring a full pig to
my house we gotta get joey roses to get
involved with hellofresh and hello fresh
start sending out joey rose's sandwiches
wow that'd be sick you said you you have
the ingredients yeah you have to put the
brussels in there you do honey yeah and
the super sod yeah and then you make it
at your home dude joey roses should have
like a joey rose's lunchable kit
that would be sick you know like like
their version of one that's fun yeah
like yeah i think he should be working
this the fairy hawks games
he should be the mascot
oh no he should be a vendor at the well
yeah that city field he should have he
should have um he should have a
stand
he should have a stand i got a gripe
is it grime time what to hold on
every time scribe time time clock i got
a gripe scrap 30 with lewis county new
york quarter to gripe
i got a gripe okay lewis county never
heard of it got accounting lewis with
lewis county new york louis gomez county
new york i got it who's jay gomez county
lewis j gomez county new york i gotta
gripe with them i got pulled over okay
it's it's about it's it's not far from
the canadian bother whoop that's the
sound of the police
that's the sound of the beast beast
is there a third one whoop whoop it goes
back go back sounded police officer
officer you know
yeah yeah krs one it's krs one from the
bronx well it might be bdp actually so
lewis county not far from the canadian
border i get pulled over i'm going 81 in
the 60s
not to be confused with gdp go ahead not
just because of gdp 81 and 65. and
listen so is everybody else let's be
honest i'm going to tell you something
right now though because it's still out
it's still out in the in the world i
haven't pleaded yet so i was going to 81
and 65.
allegedly
[Applause]
so
i
said the officer says i would have i
would have let you slide on this but i
can't look past 81 and a 65. let's let's
let's role play
okay
i'm draw i'm driving i'm the cop you're
pulled over i'm pulled over excuse me
sir yes excuse me
i noticed that you were doing 81 on the
65. yeah do you like to explain yourself
um
uh good morning officer i um it's it's
it's one o'clock good afternoon and he
actually did say he actually swear to
god because i i had my i was fumbling my
things he goes are you on a substance
and i was like no i'm just nervous right
so so okay so we'll go back in um
sir are you is something wrong are you
on a substance of some sort of some sort
no
i'm just a little nervous because i
don't know why i've been pulled over oh
you don't know why you've been pulled
though do you want to take a guess i
mean i think maybe i was going a little
bit faster a little bit faster than the
speed limit you were going 16 miles an
hour faster
in relation to 65 miles an hour as the
speed limit you were going about 25 too
fast
i totally understand i majored in math
there's no one else on the road um i
apologize for going was there an
emergency
he you know i do have to get back home
to staten island um i haven't been with
my uh kids uh for a few days and um i do
i just would like to say no more
get out of here
get out of here i have a soft spot for
family and children you would just let
me go oh that was oh that was my version
though that was my
that's who i was becoming in my head the
guy that a hard-nosed carpet that had
soft spots let me let me tell you what
the officer said to me when i said that
because i really did say that said yes i
do have i just want to get home to my
kids let me ask you a question
what's this on your front seat
that's um
smells like [ __ ]
that's what it is is it mushroom no it's
[ __ ] it takes doesn't smell like [ __ ]
so
it's a [ __ ] yeah
oh that'd be awesome why are you
fumbling did you eat [ __ ] yeah
he says to me he says to me i have i
have children too and i'm not driving 81
miles an hour in a 65
in one piece whoa
and dude that's check and mate i know so
i said i said fair enough
so you should have said i can't see one
of my daughters in one piece she is
missing a leg yeah and then you try to
pull it as strings
yeah i said i officer i can't see my
daughter in one piece anymore since she
was broken emotionally right yes she
shattered she shattered so
little pieces shout out oprah shout out
oprah yeah um
so shout out to ashley simpson all the
pieces pieces
pieces of me or is that avril lavigne i
don't know don't know um so
so
shout out ashley simpson shout out
ashford and simpson
solid solid as a rock yeah that song no
look what do you mean it's the most
famous song in the 80s
we built it up and now it's solid solid
as a rock
that's why they're changing the thrill
is rich
okay solid as a rock yeah let's see one
second if i've ever heard this song or
not
it's
feeling like no
unless hold on how do you know this song
pimp yeah of course you know it yeah it
was in grand theft auto
i was like that was the before you were
solid ashford and simpson yeah okay
we can't play this planet
football fans the first sunday of the
nfl season is here i actually have my
fantasy football draft on labor day
and draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl is
giving new customers a canvas offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season
right now new customers can bet just
five dollars and get 200
in free bets instantly and as an added
bonus for week one everyone can
experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion it's simple but on
an nfl team to win and if your team
leads by 10 at any point during the game
you get paid instantly even if your team
loses download the draftkings sportsbook
app right now and use the promo code hey
babe to get 200 in free bets instantly
when you place a five dollar bet this
sunday that's code hey babe only at
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl minimum asian
eligibility restrictions applies see
show notes for details
ship station baby you know it we love it
here we've been talking about it for a
long long time
if you are getting ready for a busy
shipping season then you need to get
ship station before you get overwhelmed
what do you have you have an online
store you have an etsy shop you have
some merch store do you have anything
that you use to ship stuff ship station
is the best thing it's a you can
ship in the best most efficient way at
the best price across all the companies
it lets you know what the best way to do
it is and you do it immediately
from home from home whether you're a big
company a little company or an
individual shipstation works for
everybody and they integrate every
platform yeah right into ship stations
so if you're selling on amazon etsy ebay
shopify you can manage all the shipping
across all those in their one dashboard
let me just tell you a little stand here
98
of companies that use shipstage for one
year become customers for
life what does that tell you that it
tells you that if you're not if you're
not using ship station you'll die that's
right yeah um and it is basically you're
getting the same rates as all the
fortune 500 companies uh join over 130
000 companies that are using uh to grow
their ecommerce business uh
yeah go to shiftstation.com right now
sign up with the promo code hey babe for
a free 60-day trial start today and get
set up before the biggest shipping
season of the year that's two months
free visit
shipstation.com click the microphone at
the top and type in code hey babe
solid as a rock no i never i swear to
christ wow i swear on my you i believe
it never once in my life heard that song
how is that possible though it was like
the grammy won the grant like it was
like a big song
you've only heard it from grand theft
auto yeah it would play in the car when
you drive around yeah and did you keep
it on hell yeah hell yeah no it's a
banger i know i i hearted it on spotify
it saved my plan the prostitute to that
song baby oh i did yeah but let me tell
you let's go back to lewis county yeah
he says to me
you know you're getting a ticket i won't
give you the points though and i you
know i said thank god
he doesn't say that but i said you know
i did my little joke that i i said on
hey babe i said thanks for not giving
the points i can't have the point oh you
said that i said i'm on he no no he said
to me i'm gonna give you a ticket i'm
not gonna put it as a cell phone ticket
i'm gonna put it as a moving violation
actually he was nice to me because he
was like you know i feel bad that's the
big thing he said he was actually nice
he was like i'll be nice to you guys i'm
going to give you a
sell a cell phone a moving violation or
a lane changing violation not a cell
phone ticket so this way you're gonna
have to pay the fine but you're not
gonna get the points and then i said
which is nice also probably illegal yeah
i'll be illegal and i said to him i said
thanks for not giving me the points i'm
on weight watchers i can't have them you
didn't that's i said and he goes
just get home safely
[Laughter]
he just wait did you tell me that i
think we said it on haven't you
absolutely i think i don't know about
the did i tell them that is it it's not
the same story though no
so i said i and he didn't laugh he
didn't laugh he bombed it bomb so then i
get home right get a ticket in the mail
a week later
i i plead
no contest or whatever so they're like
oh they sent me a letter back they say
if you want to plead no contest you have
to come up here and appear so i'm
thinking i'll get the lawyer i'll do
what you do
i say whatever [ __ ] it so i'll just say
you know what guilty i'll just do guilty
get rid of it they sent me back the
guilty with a hundred and seventy three
dollar fine no option to pay via credit
card it has to be a not even a person
check or money order no no not a
personal check a money order it has to
be a certified check or a [ __ ] money
order oh come on it's ridiculous so now
you have you literally have a chore to
do i have a choice you can't just pay
the penalty you have to go get a
certified check my question to the room
is to the audience is do they do that on
purpose to get more money knowing that
they're trying to make it harder for you
so you keep getting penalties so why
would you get why would you why would it
be more money because because now i you
know i may forget to do it if if it was
if it was via credit card or personal it
would be done
done well parking tickets here you could
pay yeah but that's what i'm saying
actually no all tickets here you could
pay i'm gonna literally write back to
lewis county i'm gonna write on the
letter back with a personal check for
173 dollars and on the front of that
envelope on the front of that thing i'm
gonna have a little note and say
there's if you don't if you don't accept
this payment guess where you can take it
up with
bloom cafe
take it up with them i'm gonna write
take it up with bloom cafe and take the
check i'm not dealing with it by the way
i wonder if bloom cafe the phones
ringing off the hook with complaints i
was told just complaining from all over
the world i was actually told by the
owners of bloom cafe if we could call it
with saying take it up a bloom cafe
because daily someone opens door yells
taking up the loom cafe and then gets on
the bus
just right outside which is right
outside yourself in my head i would love
it if if bloom cafe like the phone was
ringing and people were just logging
complaints with them
like just just from anything yeah like
you know all over the yelp
you know
they had a problem with the vacuum
cleaner on
amazon it's like the elves like love the
muffins here by the way i got a red
light ticket in midtown and i don't
understand what's going on
lodge your go on to bloom cafe's yelp
and take anything off
yeah
you gotta give them five stars yes you
gotta write something complimentary
about them but then log any complaint
you have in the world in the same health
review so you gotta go you say go to
this place it's awesome five stars i
love the coffee also though uh you know
i i i i i i what five stars five stars
on the on the vegan muffins they're
amazing love the coffee the service was
great that's why i stayed in the holiday
inn and the air broke yeah yeah
yeah
why does ukraine yet
need yet another money package from the
u.s is this what i voted for and then
just keep going
um we'll wait bloom cafe we'll wait yeah
um dude speaking of speaking of of of
hottie boom bodies yeah you were on the
hot ones yes i did the hot ones truth or
dab we want to i want to know because we
can see you and and and and myrrh and q
on the hot ones we can see that just go
to impractical jokers play truth or dab
on hot ones we can see that and and i
want to watch but i want to know what
was the aftermath for you what was what
was the [ __ ] like the next day after
after a day like that okay so
behind the scenes yes i will so i
i i always
wanted to do hot ones okay because
because you're a hottie because sean the
host evans is so amazing at what he does
he's almost like a nardwar you know
nordwars
what's a nardwar
nardwar is a canadian uh
i don't know music aficionado slash
interview like a
journalist interviewer it's like a weird
al yankovic version of
jeffrey gurion okay okay and he has like
unbelievable research team and
encyclopedic knowledge of the people
that he he springs the interviews on
them
a lot of times it's mostly musicians and
they'll be coming out of a door in a
back alley and he'll be like hey i'm
nardwar and i want to interview or maybe
they might set it up too but a lot of
times he's like they're not prepared for
it and then he asks them questions that
blows their balls off because he knows
he finds stuff out then no one knows
like do you have an example of a
question he asked someone or nothing
like you'd just be like you know when
you were like five and you had a record
that you lost and it was your favorite
record like here's the record and like i
why is this record special to you and
like rappers are like crying yeah really
swear to god pretty dope i'll look him
up it's cool yeah and so but anyway
sean's not like that but he's such a
good interview if you watch hot ones
yeah he like oh yeah yeah you know he
just makes the interview so interesting
um he just is a really good
conversationalist right and he's known
for that and so i was like i would love
to have a conversation with her ours was
more on the jokey side because this is
more of a little game it's like truth or
dare and if you can't answer the
question you have to eat the wing so
it's not a straight interview um this
this version but anyway always wanted to
do it but you know i have a weak
constitution yes and i i can't handle
any scoville unit no let alone two right
like you know like there's the things
have a 1 million scoville units it's
made from ghost pepper and pepper x and
all that [ __ ] like almost like you can't
even serve it in a restaurant like it's
too spicy no i asked him what is the
business model behind these sauces
because there's no how do they sustain a
business because
they they're not make fit for human
consumption i told him that yeah on this
thing and he said yes people just buy
them to like do this and be like
they buy them to hurt themselves yes
they buy them to maybe get a chance to
go to the er sadistic yeah except for
the people that really they like it but
i think that's like one percenters okay
okay so that's it like that's what i so
i had that on the pod and i knew it was
gonna be bad i texted a bunch of people
who were on it already friends to ask
them like what to do and what not to do
and i got some advice
uh what was some of the advice okay so
they give you water and milk okay the
milk helps more the water is less
but the goal is to not take a drink of
anything and get through them
on the regular show there's nine wings
or ten and it starts are you flexing
your chest pex
excuse me
are you flexing your pecs i just wanted
to i just wanted to let the audience
know what's up because i i think i've
noticed that like a handful of times
thus far i noticed you gold pops
sometimes when you know i'm just
actively listening i i think about the
audience at home and i want to just let
them know don't [ __ ] with me
yeah that's like yeah that's like
hulkamania going wild right there that's
why i let them know pop it right now
[Laughter]
wow babe it's actually uh uh
uh it's actually fun and unsettling at
the same time there you go i think maybe
because the chains are something that
the chains aren't giving you it looks
like it almost looks like they have
their own mind that your boobs yeah
you're attached
can you flex you can flex
lean forward and i bet you could do it
i no i don't
have you practiced this
i just always have been able to do it
even when i'm not i think if you do
chest workouts it's probably there well
i do push-ups it's what i do yeah yeah
yeah i don't know
anyway i've been enjoying it okay um
so what was they saying so you're not
sure in an interview it goes gradually
hotter but on this one they start with
the hottest there's only three hot hot
hot ones okay so there's no build up
and they just go right you're at level
10. so uh a few people one person told
me they asked me what kind of milk i
want i said they gave me the list i said
i'll take almond that's what i drink
normally little did i know
you need a high fat almond is not the
one that helps once it's the whole milk
mid interview i stopped down i said
bring me a whole milk right now i need a
whole milk um
but i was told you're going to want to
go to the milk a lot
don't go to it that much because the
last thing you want
is the most hottest wings on the planet
and then a just a belly full of those
with whole milk
so he said use it to help but don't keep
downing it
um
did you eat leading up to this did you
eat i don't think i ate no um i was
nervous and so what i did was and i know
this is like
people aren't even supposed to drink the
milk but i you see it on the table i
came with my lanta
i showed up with a milan i don't think
anyone's ever done that and i just said
look i'm already trying to get to i'm
not trying to prove anything anyone i'm
not a tough guy
so i'm afraid already right now and i
already like like sometimes tabasco is
hot for me right all right so i i drank
the i said i'll try not to it i took the
first bite
i took the first bite within one minute
i ripped open the atlanta uh my lantern
i was gonna she couldn't do my lantern
because i wanted to coat my stomach
because i was worried about my ass later
on yeah yeah yeah but luckily there's
probably no preventing your ass from
having
yeah interesting but i will tell you
though it was the most i am
[Laughter]
make a conversation that didn't happen
yeah um um so i i ended up drinking my
winter all the milk and all the water on
a second glass of milk dude it doesn't
go away the only time there's any relief
is the second the milk hits your mouth
and if you hold the milk in your mouth
for even like 10 seconds it doesn't work
anymore and the pain is so much that you
can't speak
it's it it takes over your whole body
wow i had to literally like i couldn't
stand still you look out of out of q and
murr you look like you're in the most
pain i mean you look like he was in pain
right there but you look like oh and the
host is eating as well at the end
he did one in solidarity that's pretty
cool yeah but that guy at this point
though his stomach is like a steel cage
he shouldn't give a [ __ ] no he he
are you stoned at all
no i wasn't stoned no that might have
helped right no possibly i don't know
dude
no dude you're in legitimate like great
sneakers thanks man um
that um yo you're like almost crying no
tears are coming down my face do you
regret like would you do it again or is
one one and done i i would do it if i
was if i did got the if i did the full
interview because it builds up and it
doesn't get that hot until like the last
three so you're saying your section
truth or dab is you just that's the
point of it it goes zero to 60 this one
got it so what is what are the moments
after this what do you do like when this
ends yeah like like because you so it
ended and then we were still really
burning and then they offered us bowls
of ice cream
and i i ate a bowl of vanilla ice cream
that helped the most the bowl of ice
cream and i had to go to a dinner after
this and meet people what yes and i was
sweating i was dude i was and my stomach
and but then by the time i ate the ice
cream at a time like i was good like a
half hour later and then what'd you get
at dinner
i ate a wagyu steak it didn't your whole
mouth for the
i thought it was going to but you know
nightmare you you didn't do to bomb
though the bomb is like the worst one
this this show is such a huge show and
and you know is like doing like a late
night show i mean it's huge numbers
imagine having to do the show because
you have to promote something really big
but showing up to the set you have a
canker sore
oh my that is would you rather do hot
ones with a canker sore would you rather
do hot ones with a canker sore or
um be abducted by isis for a week oh ice
is easy isis for a week yeah for real
easy interesting what are they going to
do to me put hot sauce on my canker i'm
already getting it done isis for a
weekend they may do nothing to you they
may just be you're getting out in a week
and you'll survive you may just be
fear-based but nothing ever happens
nothing ever happens but this is canker
short 20 minutes but by the way when you
put the
swing in your mouth your whole mouth
feels like a canker yeah it doesn't
matter
it's it's rough dude it was rough it it
it's oh and i told you i told you this
but
they gave me those sources i have them i
had them we could do them next episode
maybe we could do them we could do them
patreon we could do them
it's
we have milk and ice cream and stuff
we'll be able to handle it
but but bro it is it is a juice let's do
it tomorrow let's do it tomorrow do you
want to try it i'll do it for the next
step we'll do it i'll do it why are you
saving your mouth for today what are you
doing because i i'm actually having a
dinner with friends tonight um who i
haven't seen some of these guys since i
went to a dinner right after this
you did now we could wait till tomorrow
because i'm not prepared mentally but
can i can i pitch something right now
just because i want to do this is that
way you can get mushrooms tonight to be
ready for tomorrow will we do mushrooms
and eat the hot sauce oh my god
is there a way to do that
i'll tell you why there's a way
i have mushrooms oh no
is that what we're doing tomorrow that's
what we're doing that's what the next
episode will be i have to clear that
with a few people clear it yeah i'm not
talking about getting smacked why don't
we micro dose mushrooms
why don't you micro dose because i tried
to micro dose one time with these little
chocolates and nothing happened do you
have the act no i mean what i was
getting i have i have i think i have i
think like a dry i think i have
chocolates and i think i i know i have
the dried mushrooms so why don't i don't
know what kind of a dose i have we have
to ask ari we also don't have to jump to
mushrooms because you recently smoked
weed for the first time what do you mean
wait when did you he smoked weed for the
first time oh yeah that's right where
did i do that why are you awakening
exclusively
why do you exclusively wait until i
leave to do all your drugs
every time i see you you're like guess
what try new drugs for the first time
yeah i'm like guess what i did fentanyl
always wanted to do it
like the most we'll do is maybe have a
glass of white wine yeah uh but then
you'll tell me oh dude i had ten ten
bucks last night i got i was off my
right i'm like why am i not around for
these i you know i don't
i i don't have an answer for that i
don't know why it just
it just comes over me like yesterday i
was not prepared to do mushrooms i woke
up that day thinking there's no way i'll
do mushrooms today then our guest adam
gilbert go follow follow adam gilbert hi
um on uh on instagram greatguy also aka
little stinker watch the christy chaos
podcast find out why um he pulled
mushrooms a bag of shrooms out of his
back pocket in a ziploc bag and he said
do you want to do mushrooms and i said
i'm not prepared to do it do you think
it'll make me too high and he goes
there's only one way to find out and you
did it and i did it well there was there
was one lead up to that chris goes i
think you're my gateway into
psychedelics and then he immediately
took out mushrooms no yeah it was like
on command it was on camera oh i know a
buddy of mine i won't name his name but
um he got invited you ready for this
let me not name any names okay can i
guess so we're saying we're not we don't
want this name out um i could tell you
off here okay but well i think the
person okay so the person throws this
through this gathering got this
gathering together method man no okay
so the person got this gathering
together and he does this once in a
while and the person is in the business
and he's developing an animated cartoon
okay with
the grateful dead okay okay the band who
is known for psychedelics 100 and so
what he did was he rented a mansion
in l.a
and he invited some friends and the
grateful dead over
and then they all did acid and they
wrote for the cart they did they
generated ideas for the cartoon and
that guy's my friend but another one of
my friends
flew out there
and and joined them and did acid for the
first time and with the grateful dead
and help them and help generate some
ideas is is and is this cartoon like it
possibly can be seen it's go it's going
to well it's it's in development
yeah
is that not the wildest thing and i
would i wouldn't there's something i
always thought acid was acid but i think
it's not acid it's just cold acid which
i think is a bad pr move for the acid
people i think it's lsd isn't it i don't
know but acid sounds like you're going
to fry yourself and so i've never i
don't want to do it lsd yeah lsd by the
way you know there's no known quantity
of of
lsd that you can overdose on there's you
can take extreme levels of lsd you'll
never overdose is that right yeah it's
like one of those i heard stories from
this party and that one person was doing
it a lot and then like ended up like
fully naked and screaming
at like
the next day no one slept or whatever
and then like some of the guys like the
grateful dead that like have been living
this life rather like oh no that just
happens all the time no worries at all
no way because people were like
people were freaking out because other
people were tripping and then this
person screaming it's like people and
they're just like and i'm told they were
like oh no no that's just that's gonna
happen just freaking out yeah but they
said it was the best time the best time
would you do you so
what what drug
are you willing to push it to the limit
with what drug are you willing that you
would say
like obviously like you probably never
do cocaine i would never do cocaine no
disrespect people do it i never do
fentanyl willingly but like no one does
fentanyl isn't fentanyl just uh no
people get microdose fentanyl that's why
no don't they pimpy don't people
microdose fentanyl um i think so yeah oh
fentanyl was just like
not a drug you did it was like no no i
mean michael jackson did it that's what
he used to do that's how he died oh yeah
but i think the people who die of
fentanyl overdoses it's because they
snorted bad coke that was filled in with
fentanyl
yeah i'm not even i'm not going anywhere
but what drug would you right now you'd
be like i'm not i'm 50 50 on all natural
i'll do weed and mushrooms wheat and
mushrooms is all you'll consider in my
ayahuasca all-natural
ayahuasca's i'll tell you what i
wouldn't rule it out i would want to
research it more and understand what the
experience is like and then see if it's
for me or not because i've heard things
where it like can heal traumatic stress
i post traumatic i heard things where it
could open some things in your mind and
get you some clarity but then i also
don't want to be like
you know in a kelp underwear with mud
all over me in a hut i'm not worrying
about my life in the middle of the
jungle that's such a good photo
that's the podcast we need to do
i have
i'm gonna i have a connection yeah
pretty high up connection
real money not elon musk money but point
three money okay they got point three
money
they got point three i may be thinking i
know who you mean okay i don't know
connect
point three money
that has
will be willing to in their backyard in
the tri-state area post
fly out
real shamans from peru that people have
to go to they bring peru here peruvian
shamans peruvian shamans okay they bring
peru they bring the shamans
to you to you yeah they bring they bring
brew
to greenwich connecticut for you for you
peruvian peru yes
shout out peruvian shout out
peru they why the country of peru hasn't
made a chocolate drink called peruhu is
beyond me um
so
so
they have been willing for a small cost
they have the money they're 0.3
to fly shamans here for a select group
of people your name came up to do
ayahuasca in the as someone who they'd
invite into the gates of their home to
do ayahuasca
in their backyard under the guidance of
peruvian shamans we can drive there and
drive home the same day i need a yes or
no answer
right now i'm going to give you five
seconds when i start i'm gonna give you
five seconds think about it i need a yes
or no answer into that camera
no questions
no questions
go
yes this has been hey babe
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe